okay I have what could be some
optimistic news for you we talked to
optimistic vaccine news now let's talk
about therapeutics this may be
optimistic and you'll see why in a
moment
Ramez severe is one of the drugs that I
told you about six weeks ago as a
candidate for treating coronavirus and
there are some very good results that
have been summarized in an actual RCT
randomly controlled trial with a placebo
and I want to walk through it with you
in detail I'll tell you all the good
things first then I'll tell you why
there is still some skepticism that is
warranted here six weeks ago I told you
about a number of drugs that were being
tested of course there was Donald
Trump's darling chloroquine that was one
recent results on those tests not good
Ramez severe from Gilead Sciences is
another one for viveur also known as a
began is being tested there's a
combination of two HIV drugs being
tested there's a long list the room des
Vere trial has just bit one one room
desert vir trial has just been done and
it's been done correctly and this will
help us to illustrate the difference
between a proper trial and one that is
not quite so good Donald Trump you might
remember praised a trial of chloroquine
because it worked really well he said
now that had a sample size of under
forty people very very small sample size
there was no control group there was no
placebo group and it was not randomized
those are problems now momentarily I'm
going to explain to you why each of
those things matter we have a new study
called adaptive kovat 19 treatment trial
or act it was randomized and it also had
a placebo group so here's what this test
found first of all it had a hundred
thousand sixty three patients good
sample size 38 people in the other
chloroquine trial would not good number
two it was randomized this is so
important because if you don't
randomized who gets the treatment versus
who gets the placebo placebo versus
who's in the control group you could on
purpose or right depending on what you
want to attribute malice or ignorance or
just bias you could on purpose or
accidentally
test the drug on the patients that are
more likely to survive anyway and then
you get very skewed results so
randomization is very very important
what was being tested was the as the
variable was how long does it take to
recover from the virus and what this
test found is that those getting Ramdas
vir recovered 31% faster than those
given a placebo now this is why the
placebo is so important if you don't
have a placebo group any improvement
from the drug could be because of
placebo you want to be able to rule out
placebo so to properly do this you give
some people the drug you give some
people a placebo and you compare the
results and people shouldn't know of
course whether they're getting the
placebo or the real drug very good that
was done so these parameters 1063
patients 31% better than placebo this
gives a p-value of under point zero zero
one very important what the hell am I
talking about what is a p-value this is
not trivial
the p-value tells you whether the
results are scientifically significant
or whether they could be the result of
mere chance the lower the p-value the
more likely that our results actually
reflect the inputs and they're not just
a coincidence let me give you an example
of a test I could do which would have a
very high p-value and you'll very
quickly understand what I mean by
coincidence imagine that you have a
normal two-sided coin it's got heads and
it's got tails there are two possible
outcomes
heads or tails if the coin is flipped
fairly meaning I'm not kind of like
dropping it so I get heads every time
you understand the more times I flip a
fair two-sided coin we would imagine I
would roughly get closer and closer to
50% heads and 50% tails imagine that I
got results after flipping the coin four
times where all four times i got heads
and it's a fair coin okay the p-value
for that study would be very very high
and what that would tell us is
could be coincidence the fact that you
flipped a fair coin four times and got
heads four times in a row would have a
high p-value because it could just be
chance and not representative of what
would be the long-term expect
expectation which is you only get heads
half the time and you get heads tails
half the time so you would be very wrong
if based on getting heads four times you
made a big bet that it would always be
heads that means there's a very high
p-value there in the study on room des
of ear we have a very low p-value it's
less than point zero zero one what that
tells us is that it is incredibly
unlikely that the patients who did
better on the drug versus the placebo
did better only by chance now in
addition to the quicker recovery thirty
one percent faster recovery for people
having room des of ear versus placebo
the mortality rate was 8% for those who
received room des aver and eleven point
six percent for those who received the
placebo
now the p-value there is point zero five
nine it's basically 0.06 in textbooks we
are told a p-value greater than 0.05
means that the results are not
statistically significant so the idea
here is people who recover seem to
recover more quickly because of the drug
and that's statistically significant
it's less clear whether the drug helps
people survive who otherwise wouldn't
but here's the thing about the point oh
five point oh six p-value there's
nothing hard and fast about 0.04 nine is
significant and 0.05 one is not it's not
a magical spot and there can be a
difference between statistically
significant and clinically significant
so in either case we can speculate and
this is mere speculation but it seems
reasonable we could imagine this trial
of a thousand people was of people
already quite ill what we would want to
see is if you give the drug earlier does
it increase survivability to a greater
degree now that's all the good news take
everything I just told you and realize
it may not
be true what I mean by that is the
following we don't actually have the
data from the study yet what we have is
a summary of data done by doctors it has
happened in the past that the summary
sometimes you go and you look at the
data and you say the summary is wrong
this is not actually what the data show
if the data have been summarized
accurately then we do have something
here to look at now in the mean time
there's been a different study of room
des aver with only a couple of hundred
people it was double-blind placebo and
it shows no benefits from room desert so
we still need more study if this this
study is accurately representing the
data that's very good now one other note
on these tests one thing that gets
difficult when you do these tests when
you have an active pandemic is that if
you suspect that you're testing a drug
that works it's keeping people alive who
otherwise might die if that's happening
it very quickly becomes a moral question
of crap how long do we keep giving
people the placebo if we might be able
to save a lot of people by giving them
the real drug now we don't know that yet
with room des de Vere my point is in
these RCTs you very quickly will
sometimes get an ethical dilemma when
you get an efficacy signal when the drug
seems to be working very important and
that's something that's going to have to
be discussed so this is how you do
science right you don't go on national
TV and say hey 36 people in France did
well everybody what do you have to lose
maybe take room des of your
prophylactically right you don't go on
sean hannity which on his program and
say hey a doctor is taking this and zinc
prophylactically and he's doing great
this is how you actually do science and
I'm glad it's being done make sure
you're following me on rizal using the
link down in the video description I
post short blog updates you can respond
to me and then I respond to you it's a
beautiful thing follow me on rizal link
right down below